- Happy weekend everybody,
today I'm taking you to
the Canadian National Exhibition
with Nina, she just wanted to get in.
(upbeat music)
So, the Canadian National Exhibition,
otherwise known as the CNE is an annual
kind of street carnival,
here in Toronto, one
of our biggest events,
of the end of summer to kind
of close out the summer.
They have rides,
they have
shows, and why we're really going
is they have all sorts
of crazy special food,
and so Hayden's going to
want to go on the rides,
Nina's going to want to
try all the crazy food,
and I'm just tagging along for the ride,
and you guys are too.
First stop is the bathroom,
cause Hayden needs to go.
- Mostly Daddy, he was freaking
out the whole car ride.
- [Evan] Hayden really
needs to go the bathroom.
So, that's where we're going to go.
- Daddy was freaking out the whole car way
saying, I need to go to the bathroom,
I'm going to relax in the car.
- Alright, well, that's kind of true.
(upbeat music)
Who did we find?
It's.
- He's not talking.
- It's your cousins.
Jeffrey and Stephanie, how was the ride?
- Good.
(upbeat music)
- [Evan] How was it?
- Good.
- Very loud.
- Dab, dab, dab.
(upbeat music)
- Hungry, I want to try the new food.
So, Nina's going to take
the kids on the rides
with her sister-in-law,
and I'm going to get something to eat.
(upbeat music)
So, I'm going to try some of
the spaghetti doughnut balls,
tomato sauce and Parmesan.
It was talked about on
various blogs here in Toronto.
So, we're going to give it
a shot, see how it tastes.
(upbeat music)
Not bad, actually.
Pretty filling, I think
I'm going to eat one,
save one for Nina, cause
she loves trying new food.
(upbeat music)
I didn't really get much,
because I wanted to
enjoy the food with you.
Cause there's lot's of options,
you want to try something?
- Yeah
- [Evan] So, I got a
Spaghetti ball doughnut.
It's a fried spaghetti ball.
They also have cinnamon and
sugar and whip cream version,
but
I got the
tomato sauce.
- It's different.
- [Evan] Yeah, ya not hungry anymore.
- Ah, I'm not that hungry.
Well, I'm hungry, but I'm not that bad.
- [Evan] It's pretty filling actually,
but there's lot's of
unique stuff in there,
that we're going to have to go in,
and you're going to
want to go nuts and try.
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Alright, let's keep going.
(upbeat music)
- [Evan] Hayden, how was it?
- Great, she leaned on me.
- [Evan] Was it good?
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- [Evan] Okay, get some food guys.
- I'm going to throw up.
- So, it's time to eat.
(upbeat music)
I'm so scared for when Hayden
actually starts to drive,
because, I kind of feel like that's
how he's going to drive all the time.
It's very scary.
I also learned that
Nina is a crazy driver.
- I'm not a crazy driver.
- That is also how she
drives in real life.
- That's not true, I'm a safety driver,
I drive better than you.
- So, if you see Nina
on the road behind you,
go the other way.
(Evan laughs)
I'm going to try the
Canadian bacon pickle ball.
You only live once, right.
Let's see how it is.
Here they are, the bacon pickle balls.
They say to put ketchup or mustard on it.
I don't know.
Let's go with some ketchup.
Bacon
pickle, where's the pickle?
Ah, there's the pickle.
How is it?
Do you like it?
Really?
- Try it.
- It's actually really good.
Surprisingly, it's really good, I like it.
- Yeah.
- Canadian bacon pickle ball, yeah.
Why you walking so funny?
I see a root beer stand, I love root bear.
Got to get me some root beer.
There it is,
yummy.
- I haven't had pop for
a long time, oh my gosh,
it's so good.
(upbeat music)
- [Evan] Someone got wet, how was it?
- Oh my god, when I got out,
I pulled my back.
- [Evan] You pulled your
what, you pulled your muscle?
Nina's wet.
How was it Hayden?
Hayden's dancing.
- The last one was scary,
it's like.
(Children yelling)
(upbeat music)
Yeah.
- [Evan] Good job Nina.
- [Hayden] Get the red one.
- Oh my god, I got scared.
- [Evan] You got scared?
Nina was scared.
(Evan laughs)
- I wasn't scared.
- [Evan] Were you scared?
- No.
I wasn't scared.
- [Evan] Only Nina.
- [Nina] Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- [Evan] Hayden's having
the purple ice cream,
how is it mister?
- [Evan] Yeah.
Nina's having,
oh, it hasn't come out yet.
There it is.
- And one more, yes.
- [Evan] Charcoal.
- How does that taste?
- [Evan] How is it?
Yummy?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Oh, the cone is hot.
- [Hayden] I can only taste stars.
- Time to give it a try.
Mmmm,
this black charcoal ice cream has been
the craze of Toronto,
hitting all the blogs.
Everybody's talking about it.
Pretty good, this kind of,
it just kind of tastes like
just kind of tastes like vanilla.
It's just vanilla.
- [Nina] Yeah, I know, it's just vanilla.
- It's just black vanilla.
People freak out over minor things,
but still very yummy vanilla.
What?
- Mmmhmm.
- [Evan] Mmmhmm,
Mmmhmm.
- The farm.
- [Evan] The farm, let's go to the farm.
(upbeat music)
Kids are getting ready for the corn maze.
- And we're going to solve it.
Don't get lost.
Don't die in there.
- We'll solve it in two seconds.
- [Evan] Don't get lost, we'll see.
We're going in the corn maze.
Hayden's going to lead us with Jeffrey.
Here we go guys.
- [Employee] Here ya go, have fun.
- [Evan] Alright, let's not get lost.
Hey, slow down.
(upbeat music)
Ya know, you guys only
solved it so quickly,
cause I was with you.
- No.
(upbeat music)
- [Evan] Nina's in line for
the Japanese street food.
Alright, so we got the kids pizza.
- [Nina] Hello.
- Hayden's really excited about his pizza,
and Nina got us some Japanese street food.
First, got to feed the kids.
Right,
look at that energy.
(Hayden laughs)
- [Evan] Ready, ready
kids, ready for your pizza?
- [Hayden] I already got my plate.
- [Evan] Oh, look at that.
- [Hayden] Oh yeah, I want
that piece right there.
- [Evan] Kay, go take it.
Grab a slice, grab a plate.
Here comes Nina.
She's very excited.
- Yes, very excited.
- [Evan] Where's Jeffrey?
- Jeffrey's here.
- [Evan] Jeffrey, grab
some pizza, let's go.
Okay, Nina, let's see what you ordered.
- Last samurai.
- [Evan] I have one of those too, right.
- Yep, same thing.
- [Evan] Okay.
- Cheese, chicken, ah, it's beef actually.
- [Evan] Cheese, chicken and beef.
Japanese street food.
- [Hayden] Looks good.
- [Evan] Last time, Nina
could barely eat it.
- [Hayden] Oh.
- [Evan] And, worth the wait.
- It's different.
- [Evan] Different, different is good.
- Nina likes trying different food.
Alright, I'm going to eat mine,
I'm excited.
Hayden's trying a bite.
- [Nina] Holy cow, that's
my big chicken, holy cow.
Hayden.
- [Evan] Hayden, how is it?
- Mmmm
Yummy?
- [Evan] It's good.
The bread is like potato.
You have a message?
No message, just a big smile,
- [Nina] Enjoy the summer.
- [Evan] Alright.
Alright, the sun is setting.
We got to take this guy home.
Thank you guys for joining us on our.
- Day trip.
Is this going to be a regular
thing, a trip to the CNE?
- Ah ha.
- An annual trip to the CNE?
- Yeah.
- Maybe, Hayden has a message?
- Yes.
- What's your message?
- Believe.
- Believe, that's a good
one, I like that message,
yet I feel like it was
stolen from somebody.
- You can stand up Katherine.
- So, thank you guys for joining us.
Nina has a message?
- Enjoy your last few days of summer.
- There ya go, thank
you guys for watching.
- And you need to believe.
- Enjoy your.
And whatever you want work, yes,
work season, bye.
- I can't get anything in, bye guys.
- Bye.